in the Russian media criticism of the
war effort was invisible it's now
creeping into the coverage
Russian history isn't what it used to be
we look at the official efforts to scrub
it clean
and Iran's supreme leader offers and
tweets his response to the continuing
demonstrations there
hello I'm Richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we provide
explanatory journalism about journalism
and the global news media we begin with
a narrative that is Shifting in Russia
since the kremlin's annexation of four
provinces in eastern Ukraine its forces
have suffered setbacks some Russian
voices on the airwaves and online have
grown more critical not of Vladimir
Putin that comes with consequences but
of the Russian military these aren't
anti-war voices for the most part those
have been silenced the pro-war Putin
faithful are now grappling with defeats
they never expected to see Russian
troops in Retreat from towns like Limon
inside the annexation Zone the generals
taking the Flack are getting it from
some public figures who carry
considerable clout online
loyalists on usually subservient State
television channels are echoing that and
Military bloggers go-to sources for
Russians trying to find more authentic
reporting from the battlefield are
painting a picture that's every bit as
Bleak the angle of this story that has
not drawn enough attention the nuclear
one and Putin's refuse to take that
option off the table
our starting point this week is Moscow
if you're a Russian in a
state-controlled new studio these days
you were advised to choose your words
very carefully
even someone like Margarita the head of
the state-owned news Outlet RT needed
reminding of that after she appeared on
another Channel rocia One the topic
Russia's unilateral annexation on
September 30th of parts of eastern
Ukraine and its military's humiliating
Retreat from some of that same territory
the very next day
foreign
it was the kind of analysis that will
get you called out
in Ukraine
the images
if you're a political player and you're
online like the oligarch evgeny
pregosian or ramzan kadirov Vladimir
Putin's man in chechnya you tend to have
more leeway but not that much so you rip
the underlings and go after Putin's
generals calling them unfit to lead on
the battlefield there's a thing in
Russians
are his good boys
so the idea is that you do not criticize
sorry criticize
people who are in charge of implementing
his decisions it's a relatively
significant moment because we have not
seen criticism coming from such
high-ranking people like adira
the church and leader ramzan khadirov
and pregosian who is an oligarchical
ally of Putin's criticized the war
effort in scathing terms they're not
alone they're important because hadirov
has sent troops from chechnya to the
Ukraine and pregosian is important
because he runs this mercenary group
called The Wagner group
foreign
they represent a larger community of
nationalists of right-wing nationalists
who want to take the gloves off the
Retreats are going down very badly most
analysts are agreed that ramzan kaderov
did not write the criticism of the Army
on his very popular telegram channel the
sort of language that was being used did
not give off the particularly strong
khadir of Vibes different groups that
are close to the Kremlin vying to place
responsibility on other groups on on
groups with whom perhaps they have
rivalries and that's really what we're
seeing now
Rumblings of Russian descent provide
glimpses into how media censorship there
works and when it does not controlling
the terminology is the easy part
don't call it a war when the Kremlin
says it's a special military operation
don't call the latest conscription order
for an extra 300 000 Russians on
mobilization
it's a partial mobilization
the problem occurs when facts on the
ground change too quickly for the
authorities to keep up and the official
guidance is late incoming media Outlets
don't know what kind of terminology they
can get away with how accurate they can
afford to be
um
if we compare what the what the state
propaganda was telling about this war at
the beginning in March and and now these
are two totally different Wars because
because back then gloves
is
not the government would definitely
support Russian troops and Russian
control and when it didn't happen the
propaganda has to explain all the
defeats and the retreats
and why the military operation that was
expected to to take like three four days
already lasts more than half a year and
there is no end in sight
Russians searching for more reliable War
reporting can no longer rely on
alternative media Outlets they have been
brought to heal Millions have turned to
the messaging app Telegram and Military
bloggers embedded with Russian forces
who offer more factual news from the
front
foreign
with followings in the hundreds of
thousands sometimes more they publish
detailed information maps of troop
movements when allowed they blog with a
pro-war perspective and are distinctly
unhappy with the news they are reporting
some of them are also calling for
military heads to roll and again we
start to see this looking for who is to
blame slutco is one of the most popular
was talking about how you know arrests
need to be made because the military are
clearly not adhering to the constitution
of accusations that are coming out
remind one of even darker times in
Russia's history and the need for sort
of purging that said these people they
are more extreme than the government so
they shouldn't be misunderstood as
that's the direction of the Kremlin but
they that they are influential people
understand that they can't can't get any
reliable information from war propaganda
on television you've got this group of
people who have very nationalist views
but at least they have give you access
to some information about what's going
on on the ground and because of this
access they became relatively
influential some of the telegram
channels they run they have millions of
subscribers because people want to get
access to the information the opposition
to this war is not from those who are
anti-war they have been repressed
sufficiently in the demonstrations the
arrests is now coming from a far right
and a Far Far Right an extremist
nationalist right but that is a very
important opposition and they have their
own apps they have their own media they
have their own newsletters it's an
important Trend to watch as the war goes
badly
of all the angles in the Ukraine Story
the Russian media have come up short on
none is bigger than the Nuclear One
Industries
President Putin's repeated threats that
that option is on the table should
Russian territory come under attack was
described by one Moscow paper as
unbelievable its editorial argued that
to allow inwards the possibility of a
nuclear conflict is a sure step towards
allowing it in reality but that was the
exception then again why would Russian
news channels be concerned by something
that some of their own anchors have been
suggesting for months now with the
apparent blessing of the Kremlin foreign
nuclear saber rattling at the at the
moment and that's a controlled and uh
narrative
effort being built inside the Kremlin of
course that's Putin trying to send the
message to the West that he would not
back off that this is not a bluff his
message has to be sort of backed by the
whole propaganda apparatus and this
question where are we all heading is uh
is is is in the air
the talk of nuclear weapons of any kind
is horrifying there is a normalization
of talk both inside Russia and on our TV
screens and in our media the
normalization is reckless insane and it
has intensified in terms of those around
Putin who are perhaps more extreme than
Putin who seem quicker use of it whereas
Putin may be using it for negotiations
this war has entered a very very
dangerous Arena and that I think has to
be reckoned with
we'll get back to Russia shortly but
first Iran where the supreme leader
Ayatollah has finally broken his silence
on the protests that began there three
weeks ago Flo Phillips now with the
details
Richard this past Monday Ayatollah
delivered a speech that was designed
both for his domestic and international
audience it was broadcast live in Iran
and Key Parts were then tweeted out
there were Harmony's first comments on
the death of Masa amini she was arrested
by the so-called morality police for not
wearing a hijab the way the Lord
dictates and reportedly died while in
their custody setting off the protests
Harmony called it a tragic incident Bart
said that the demonstrations were quote
schemes designed by the U.S the fake
Zionist regime and some treasonous
Iranians abroad as evidence of foreign
meddling Harmony pointed to the messages
of support from Western politicians and
even Western media coverage of the
protests reporting that he said was
openly supportive and unlike the
coverage given to protests elsewhere
a
foreign
[Music]
was talking about a statement issued by
the Biden White House on Iran's jamming
of internet access it said quote the U.S
is making it easier for Iranians to
access the internet by a secure outside
platforms and services
videos images and messages posted online
by Iranians many of which have shown
women removing and burning the hijab in
public have provided a sense of what is
happening there the U.S which has pushed
for maintaining sanctions against Iran
has chosen this story this moment to
ease some of them to help keep Iranians
online
thanks Flo back to Russia and Ukraine a
story that beyond the fighting on the
battlefield Pit's one version of History
against another the Russian president
provided a glimpse into his thinking
last year when the Kremlin published an
essay in Vladimir Putin's name in which
he argued that Russians and ukrainians
are of the same Slavic Nation he did it
again just prior to the invasion it is
all part of a new historical discourse
one that emphasizes Russia's status as a
great power and mythologizes the
country's past among the victims of that
rewrite are Russians themselves those
who contest the Erasure of History
that includes one organization Memorial
that has spent years researching and
remembering the victims of political
repression in what was the Soviet Union
suddenly it has found itself on the
wrong side of the law it's been shut
down the listening posts Tariq NAFA now
from Moscow in a report filmed the month
before The Invasion on the battle over
historical memory in Russia
[Music]
December 28 2021 an abysmal year for
free expression in Russia comes to a
fitting conclusion with the judge
ordering the closure of the country's
oldest human rights organization
[Music]
for more than 30 years Memorial had
preserved records and artifacts from
Joseph Stalin's great perch when show
trials Mass arrests and executions
touched every level of society
Memorial's human rights Center which has
also been shut down kept track of
political prisoners in Russia Today
assembling a vast online database of
repression in Russia
what happened in court last year was
that the state exposed itself the
prosecutor spun the idea that Memorial
does not paint the history of our
country in a positive light that it
demonizes the USSR as a terrorist State
when we started Memorial the true scale
of the repression was absolutely hidden
Memorial did a lot to open up the
archives what is happening today is not
just a regression it is a crime against
citizens of Russia because citizens have
the right to know their history
the main function of Memorial was to
gather evidence of the national tragedy
our country experienced
my grandfather Mark michalovich Albert
was shot on November the 1st 1937.
more than 1 000 people like him were
shot the same day
they wanted to force him to admit that
he was a trotskyist even though there
wasn't a single shred of evidence to
support that
this was the memory gathered and
researched by a memorial
Memorial started functioning as a
political organization and that really
is a Pity I remember Memorial when it
was created at the end of the 1980s as
an organization aiming to help the
relatives of people who were imprisoned
and to remember them
nowadays it has become an anti-russian
political organization
's argument Echoes that of the state
which has grown more defensive of
Russia's historical Legacy
when Memorial first surfaced in the late
1980s things were different citizens
were seeking out the truth about Soviet
state Terror and relatively little stood
in their way
in 1990 members of Memorial installed
this the solovetsky stone here in Moscow
to honor victims of political repression
in Soviet Russia it was a period of
glasnost openness and transparency when
Russians were learning about the
atrocities committed under Joseph Stalin
the decision to put it here in the
Bianca Square was significant we're
right across the road from what was the
kgb's headquarters now home to the FSB
the Federal Security Services but 30
years on some of those dark chapters
from Russia's past are being erased
history is being Rewritten
[Music]
When Vladimir Putin came to power
practically all the archives were closed
the people who exercise power in Russia
Today a former KGB officers or members
of the foreign intelligence and the FSB
they are ideological supporters of the
KGB and the USSR
they want to pretend that there was a
short period of repression but in
reality the whole governance system of
the Soviet state was based on violence
for the current Russian leadership the
Kremlin history is a tool for
introducing certain myths into people's
minds what we see today is the Revenge
of the State security agencies which
were in retreat in the early 1990s the
state no longer wants to know the truth
about itself it builds its own history
and arranges it to fit its ideological
purposes
a campaign to sanctify Russia's war
heroes is playing out in popular culture
and in public space
the government has championed patriotic
films that lionized the military and
affirm its use of force
was
[Music]
many of these state-funded Blockbusters
Center on Stalin's leadership in what is
known in Russia as the Great Patriotic
War
foreign
Moscow is filled with tributes to
historical figures Patriots who ensured
the survival of the state
it's where you can find pop-up
propaganda showcasing Russia's military
Arsenal
some of these murals are sponsored by
historical associations run by senior
officials close to the president
including this one opposite the Kremlin
it was commissioned by the Russian
military Historical Society where
Mikhail merkov a scientific director
the victory of the Soviet Army in the
second world war has a crucial role in
how Russians self-identify we have to
hold on to some constants such as our
victories during the Patriotic War of
1812 the first world war or the Great
Patriotic War these allow us to feel
self-sufficient in this world we can say
to other nations we gave you Freedom we
live in a world that was created by the
Soviet Union in 1945.
missing from that narrative are
inconvenient periods of History like
August 1939 when Joseph Stalin and Adolf
Hitler agreed to a non-aggression pact
arguably Paving the way for a world war
that started one week later
over time Stalin's Legacy once so
discredited has been rehabilitated in
2019 a survey by the lebada center found
70 percent of Russians thought he had
played a positive role in Russian
history
people are constantly told that without
Stalin the Russians would not have won
the war the stallion
Putin has nothing else to offer Russian
citizens he cannot offer them wealth and
prosperity and that is why he is only
offering the myths of some great periods
in history
having shaped a grand historical
narrative about Russia's place in the
world Vladimir Putin now wants to
protect it a new National Security
strategy signed by Putin in 2021 says
traditional Russian values and
historical memory are under attack and
must be defended before Russia invaded
Ukraine this week Putin once more
revealed his obsession with writing past
wrongs by questioning Ukraine's
historical rights to existence
I would never have believed it 30 years
ago if someone would have told me all
this would begin to repeat itself we
have not learned any worthy lessons from
history any state any community of
people often live with myths about the
past but all myth-making begins with a
set of values what is valuable for the
group of people now leading Russia to
remain in power forever to consume to
occupy we can see that now with the
revanchist speech on Ukraine and to
convince everyone that the state is an
absolutely sacred object which cannot be
encroached on in any way
[Music]
and finally analyzing the words and the
messaging of world leaders can be taxing
what gets said the tone the delivery but
have you ever paid attention to the way
they walk those few moments when a
president or a prime minister heads for
the cameras can reveal a thing or two
that their speeches do not Stefan Leon's
Hershberger is a German comedian and
actor his impression of the way various
global leaders walk is all over Tick
Tock these days see if you can spot the
leader before the reveal we'll see you
next time here at the listening post
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]